some of the biggest characters from
Marvel Comics were already tied up
spider-man Fantastic Four x-men so the
idea of Marvel Studios coming along and
launching itself this sort of upstart
mission but doing it without the biggest
guns there was some skepticism just a
big library that we have all we had to
do is take the best of it we were tasked
with doing two movies right off the bat
we chose Hulk because we believed that
there was more to be showcased out of
the whole character and we chose Iron
Man because we believed in the content
and the concept in the comic I had my
eyes open I came to realize that I have
more to offer this world than just
making things to blow up it's one of our
most interesting characters I don't
believe in the tears I don't believe in
a tear be tear CT it's up to us to make
them all a because in the comics they
are you have a character's been around
45 years 50 years that's in a character
that's in a franchise and then it's our
burden to convince the rest of the movie
going public
that's the case Marvel's assembling a
universe
March 18th on ABC